Son objectif scientifique principal
était de repérer des planètes extrasolaires.
Comment ? En scrutant une région fixe du ciel, cette zone quadrillée.
Il a surveillé la luminosité
de plus de 150 000 étoiles à l'intérieur de ce champ
sans interruption pendant quatre ans,
enregistrant un point de données toutes les 30 minutes.
Kepler cherchait ce qu'on appelle un transit astronomique.
C'est quand l'orbite d'une planète est alignée à notre ligne de mire
au moment où elle passe devant une étoile.
L'obstruction d'une partie de la lumière de l'étoile
se traduit par la baisse de cette courbe.
L'équipe de la NASA a donc dû mettre au point des ordinateurs spéciaux
pour détecter ces transits dans les données de Kepler.
Au moment de la diffusion de ces premières données,
les astronomes à Yale se posaient une autre question intéressante :
et si les ordinateurs avaient loupé quelque chose ?
Nous avons alors lancé un projet de science grand public, Planet Hunters,
pour que des gens ordinaires examinent les mêmes données.
Le cerveau humain est étonnamment doué pour la reconnaissance des formes,
parfois même plus que les ordinateurs.
Mais cela a fait l'objet de beaucoup de scepticisme.
Ma collègue Debra Fischer, fondatrice du projet,
avait reçu des remarques comme :
« Tu délires. Un ordinateur ne peut pas rater une telle chose. »
C'était l'enjeu typique de l'homme contre la machine.
Et nous serions aux anges si nous trouvions une seule planète.
Quand j'ai rejoint l'équipe il y a quatre ans,
on était à deux ou trois.
Aujourd'hui, grâce à la collaboration de plus de 300 000 passionnés de science,
nous en sommes à des douzaines.
Nous avons aussi trouvé une des étoiles les plus mystérieuses
de la galaxie.
Pour mieux comprendre ceci,
laissez-moi vous montrer à quoi ressemble un transit normal.
À gauche, c'est la quantité de lumière.
Au bas, c'est le temps.
La ligne blanche, ce qu'on appelle une courbe photométrique,
indique la lumière en provenance de l'étoile.
Quand une planète transite une étoile, elle bloque un peu de sa lumière.
La profondeur de ce transit reflète la taille de l'objet lui-même.
Prenons l'exemple de Jupiter.
Les planètes sont rarement plus grosses.
Jupiter diminuerait la luminosité d'une étoile de 1 %.
Comme la Terre est onze fois plus petite que Jupiter,
son signal serait quasi invisible dans les données.
Retournons à notre énigme.
Il y a quelques années, les volontaires passaient les données au crible
quand ils ont remarqué un signal bizarre en provenance de l'étoile KIC 8462852.
Ils ont fait ces observations en mai 2009
et ont commencé à en discuter dans les forums en ligne.
Ils se disaient qu'un objet comme Jupiter
pouvait bien occasionner une telle baisse dans la luminosité
mais qu'il devait être gigantesque.
Voyez-vous, les transits ne durent normalement que quelques heures,
mais celui-ci a duré presqu'une semaine.
Ils disaient aussi que l'objet avait l'air asymétrique.
La courbe, au lieu d'avoir la forme d'un « U » parfait comme celle de Jupiter,
était étrangement inclinée, comme vous pouvez le constater à gauche.
Ceci indiquait
que l'objet qui bloquait la lumière
n'était pas sphérique comme une planète.
Après d'autres baisses de la courbe,
tout s'est calmé pendant quelques années.
Puis, en mars 2011, nous enregistrions ceci.
La luminosité de l'étoile chute de 15 %.
C'est énorme, comparé à une planète
qui causerait une simple baisse de 1 %.
La courbe ne présente pas d'irrégularités,
mais elle est aussi asymétrique.
La luminosité diminue graduellement
au cours d'une semaine
avant de subitement reprendre son cours normal
en l'espace de quelques jours.
À la suite d'une autre accalmie qui s'achève en février 2013,
les choses deviennent vraiment bizarres.
Un ensemble complexe de chutes apparaît sur la courbe de lumière.
Elles perdurent une centaine de jours,
jusqu'à la fin de la mission de Kepler.
Ces chutes ont des formes très variées.
Certaines sont aigües, d'autres arrondies.
Elles sont aussi de durée variable,
allant de deux jours à plus d'une semaine.
Il y a d'autres hausses et baisses à l'intérieur de certaines courbes
comme si plusieurs événements indépendants y étaient superposés.
Au même moment, la luminosité chute de plus de 20 %.
Cela veut dire, d'après nos calculs,
que l'objet possède une superficie mille fois supérieure à celle de la Terre.
C'est extraordinaire !
Quand les volontaires ont remarqué ceci,
ils ont signalé à notre équipe que ce phénomène étrange méritait
d'être étudié plus en profondeur.
Alors, quand l'équipe a examiné les données,
on a d'abord cru qu'elles contenaient une erreur quelconque.
Mais notre inspection méticuleuse a confirmé
que ces données étaient fiables.
Alors, ce phénomène devait forcément être astrophysique,
c'est-à-dire qu'un véritable objet spatial obstruait la lumière d'étoile.
À ce stade, on a décidé
d'apprendre tout ce qu'on pouvait sur cette étoile
pour dénicher des indices sur ce qui se passait vraiment.
Les « citoyens scientifiques » nous ont à nouveau accompagnés
pour la prochaine étape
de ce projet de « science en action ».
D'abord, un participant a suggéré que l'étoile était peut-être si jeune
qu'elle était encore entourée de nuages de matière interstellaire.
Puis, un autre participant
a suggéré que l'étoile avait déjà des planètes
et que deux d'entre elles étaient entrées en collision,
un peu comme durant la formation de la Lune.
Ces deux hypothèses ne pourraient expliquer qu'une partie des données
parce que l'étoile en question n'a pas l'air d'être très jeune.
Aucune lueur ne se dégage de la matière qui aurait dû
être chauffée par la lumière
d'une jeune étoile ou par l'impact et la poussière d'une collision.
Quelqu'un d'autre a proposé
l'hypothèse d'un vaste essaim de comètes
qui passerait devant l'étoile sur une orbite très elliptique.
Bien que cette idée-là concorde avec nos observations,
elle m'a l'air un peu tirée par les cheveux, étant donné qu'il faudrait
des centaines de comètes pour reproduire ce scénario
dans la réalité.
Et on parle seulement de celles
qui passent, par pur hasard, entre nous et l'étoile,
alors on en aurait véritablement besoin de milliers ou de dizaines de milliers.
Mais parmi toutes nos mauvaises idées,
celle-ci était la moins mauvaise.
Alors, on est allés de l'avant en publiant nos constatations.
C'était un des articles les plus difficiles que j'aie jamais eu à écrire.
Les scientifiques sont censés publier des résultats.
On n'en avait pas.
On a essayé d'arranger les choses avec un titre accrocheur :
« Où est le flux ? »
Je vous laisserai deviner l'acronyme.
[What The Fuck/Merde] (Rires)
L'histoire ne se termine pas ici.
À l'époque où j'écrivais l'article,
j'ai rencontré un collègue, Jason Wright.
Il travaillait sur les mêmes données.
Il me dit que l'extrême précision du télescope lui donnait la capacité
de détecter des méga-structures extraterrestres autour des étoiles
mais ne l'avait pas fait.
Je lui ai montré les données étranges que nos volontaires avaient recueillies,
et il me dit :
« Mince, Taby,
je vais devoir réécrire mon article. »
Nos explications naturelles étaient faibles
et on était maintenant curieux.
Il fallait trouver un moyen d'éliminer l'hypothèse extraterrestre.
Ensemble, nous avons persuadé un autre collègue qui travaille
sur le projet SETI, « Recherche d'une intelligence extraterrestre »,
que ce serait un objet exceptionnel à surveiller de près.
On a rédigé une proposition de recherche
à envoyer au plus grand radiotélescope au monde, à l'observatoire de Green Bank.
Quelques mois plus tard,
des nouvelles de cette proposition ont fuité dans la presse.
Il y a eu des milliers d'articles de presse,
plus de 10 000, consacrés à cette étoile.
Sur Google Images,
vous allez voir ceci.
Vous vous demandez peut-être : « Mais Tabby, comment
est-ce que les aliens expliquent cette courbe de lumière ? »
D'accord, imaginez une civilisation bien plus avancée que la nôtre.
Dans des circonstances hypothétiques,
cette civilisation aurait épuisé toutes les réserves d'énergie de sa planète.
Où en trouver encore ?
Ils ont leur étoile, tout comme nous avons notre soleil.
S'ils arrivent à capter plus d'énergie de cette étoile,
cela répondrait à leurs besoins énergétiques.
Alors ils construiraient d'immenses structures.
Ces méga-structures,
comme d'énormes panneaux solaires, s'appellent des sphères de Dyson.
L'image ci-dessus montre
des croquis artistiques qui essaient d'imaginer ces sphères.
C'est difficile de donner une idée de l'immensité de ces trucs,
mais essayez d'imaginer ceci.
La distance entre la Terre et la Lune est de 380 000 km.
La partie la plus simple d'une de ces structures
serait cent fois plus grosse que cela.
Elles sont colossales.
Imaginez une de ces structures en orbite autour d'une étoile.
Vous voyez comment cela produirait des anomalies dans les données,
comme des chutes irrégulières et peu naturelles.
Mais même les méga-structures extraterrestres
n'échappent pas aux lois physiques.
Vous voyez, tout ce qui consomme beaucoup d'énergie
va produire de la chaleur.
On n'a pas détecté de rayons de chaleur.
Peut-être est-ce simplement
qu'il émet ces rayons dans un sens opposé à la Terre.
Une autre de mes hypothèses préférées
est que c'était une bataille interplanétaire qui a entraîné
la destruction catastrophique d'une des planètes.
J'admets que cela produirait beaucoup de poussière.
Nous n'en avons pas trouvé.
Mais puisqu'on parle déjà d'extraterrestres,
comment être sûrs qu'ils n'ont pas nettoyé
tous les débris de cette bataille
à des fins de recyclage ?
(Rires)
Vous voyez, cela peut donner des scénarios très créatifs.
Nous voici donc face
à une situation qui pourrait s'avérer être
un phénomène naturel qu'on ne comprend pas
ou de la technologie extraterrestre qu'on ne comprend pas non plus.
En tant que scientifique, je penche plutôt vers l'explication naturelle,
mais je crois autant que vous qu'il serait cool de trouver des aliens.
Quoi qu'il en soit, il y a quelque chose de nouveau et d'intéressant à découvrir.
Alors, c'est quoi la suite ?
On doit continuer à observer cette étoile
pour mieux comprendre ce qu'il se passe.
Mais les astronomes professionnels, comme moi,
ont des ressources limitées pour ce genre de projet
et Kepler est déjà sur une autre mission.
Mais je suis heureuse qu'une fois de plus,
les citoyens passionnés de science soient venus à la rescousse.
Vous voyez, cette fois-ci, des astronomes amateurs,
munis de leurs télescopes dans leurs arrière-cours,
ont immédiatement commencé à observer le ciel tous les soirs,
avec leur propre équipement.
J'ai hâte de voir ce qu'ils découvriront.
L'étoile aurait pu ne jamais être trouvée par nos ordinateurs
simplement parce qu'ils ne la cherchaient pas !
Ce qui est encore plus formidable, c'est qu'il nous reste beaucoup
de données à recueillir.
D'autres missions seront lancées
pour observer des millions d'autres étoiles
à travers tout le ciel.
Quelles seraient les conséquences
de la découverte d'une autre étoile comme celle-là ?
Et si nous n'en trouvions jamais d'autre ?
Merci.
(Applaudissements).